benvenuti in un nuovissimo da oggi
parleremo di acconciature terribili e
tagli tra manny e dove trovarli non
proprio cioè si ci sono delle cose
abbastanza tram n
ci sono anche delle cose che non stavano
così mare di cosa sto parlando della mia
è solo a grande richiesta infatti mi
avete chiesto di parlarvi di tutti i
miei cambi di look per quanto riguarda i
capelli quindi le quinte che ho fatto se
ne ho fatte le acconciature se tenevo i
capelli mossi tra i capelli ricci un po
appunto la storia dei miei capelli prima
di partire col video mi raccomando se
non avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi al
mio canale e cliccate sulla campanella
per ricevere una notifica tutte le volte
che pubblicherò un nuovo video partiamo
con le prime due foto chi è questa
bambina e ricciolina ero io ovviamente
quindi per chi non sapesse io ho i
capelli ricci da piccola gli avevo
riccissimi nel senso che mia mamma mi
racconta sempre che mi svegliavo al
mattino ovviamente avendo studiato
durante la notte con richiamava i
fusilli cioè propri ricciolini piccolini
stretti quindi proprio una sorta di
capelli afro
poi ovviamente crescendo espirando lì
non sono non hanno più quel riccio però
come potete notare i boccoli ni sembravo
un angioletto
in realtà è una piccola peste chiusa
parentesi
quindi passo un'infanzia d'ariccia
un'infanzia che purtroppo ha
attraversato anche un momento traumatico
per quanto riguarda i capelli preparate
i fazzoletti per questo evento ve lo
dico già non c'è una foto perché facevo
poche foto in quel momento delle dita e
adesso capirete il perchè mia mamma mi
porta dal parrucchiere che c'era vicino
davanti alla mia scuola niente dovevo
accorciarli leggermente i capelli e mia
mamma i tempi aveva un caschetto un
carrello mi ricordo comunque arrivavano
che meno qua e io dolcissima proprio un
angioletto guardo la parrucchiera e dico
guarda io li vorrei come la mamma
la parrucchiera che evidentemente aveva
la giornata no oppure aveva voglia di
tagliare io non sto scherzando ragazzi
mi ha fatto i capelli a spazzola a
spazzola cioè io ero un basco un bambino
inizialmente non mi rendevo bene conto
di quello che fosse successo col passare
dei giorni con i compagni che mi
prendevano in giro che mi chiamavano
maschiaccio
io che comunque amavo amavo legarmi
capelli farmi le acconciature non fare
niente di tutto ciò ho iniziato
veramente a soffrire di questa cosa e
per me lo dico sempre è stato il mio
primo vero trauma
cioè io per tot anni non sono più voluto
entrare da un parrucchiere perché avevo
la fobia delle forbici c'è sempre luogo
comune delle donne insomma che non
vogliono farsi tagliare più di tanti
capelli però immaginatevi una bambina
che passa tre anni della sua infanzia
quei capelli da maschio c'è magari gente
a cui piace ovviamente però io volevo
avere lunghi o comunque fino alle spalle
e invece per un errore nel parrucchiere
visto ritrovate aveva quindi a spazzola
va bene essendo riccio una volta che i
capelli hanno iniziato a crescere
stavo ancora peggio perché avevo questi
ricciolini la metà sospesi nell'aria
insomma ragazzi vi dico la verità per 23
anni mi sono vergognato tantissimo dei
miei capelli fino a quando insomma è
arrivati più o meno qua sopra le spalle
ed erano gestibili però veramente è
stato forse il periodo più brutto della
mia vita
dopo di ciò più o meno alle medie ho
iniziato forse anche per questo trauma
che avevo subito a voler cambiare quindi
non mi voglio più vedere riccia andavo
con la mamma dal parrucchiere vi faccio
stirare anch'io
oppure ai tempi andava di modissima
parte il freeze eco la piastra frise
quindi come facevo la piega liscia e poi
due ciuffetti po ha fatti col frise c'è
una roba proprio una pacchianata senza
senso però io uscivo al parrucchiere mi
sentivo top in questo compiuto anno sono
riuscito a trovare più di tanto sul su
questi periodi che vi ho appena
raccontato ma ho trovato questa foto
questa foto risale a una delle mie prime
serate in discoteca se non la prima la
seconda sicuro aprire una parentesi
lunga due ore sull'out fit ma questo è
tutto un altro video mi concederei sui
capelli liscio piastrato già i tempi
insomma amavo e charme i capelli e
sicuramente per tutto quello del liceo
la maggior parte dei giorni avevo i
capelli lisci cioè meghni lasciamo molto
poco ricci questa foto invece risale
all'estate in se non sbaglio della
maturità
quindi io selvaggia io molto chiara
quindi questi colpi di sole non so cosa
erano comunque ero molto chiara sulle
punte soprattutto riccio selvaggio
periodo durato poco perché poi è
subentrata la schiaritura proprio
definitiva il biondo il mio primo biondo
totale cioè non erano più solo lei colpi
di sole era proprio biondo aprirei una
parentesi su quanto guardandomi adesso
mi veda insomma stranissima non mi
piaccio però ai tempi mi piaceva questa
foto è di un backstage di uno shooting
che avevo fatto questa piena foto
appunto di scena lì insomma di questo
shooting è notare il tatuaggio sparita
completamente riccia e bionda non mi
piaccio poi mi farete sapere voi nei
commenti come stavo
quest'altra foto è sempre del periodo
del biondo da notare i carriera bianchi
che avete già avuto modo di conoscere
nel video sulla mia collezione di
occhiali
questo è stato forse l'unico giorno in
cui lo indossati e poi li ho buttati
anzi sono buttati dalle 5 vabbè in senso
metaforico non si sono ripromessi e
rullo di tamburi
questa è sempre bionda il mio periodo
del biondo ma io parlerei di questa
acconciatura di quella che io chiamo la
cofana la cofana è stato un leit motiv
della mia vita per quanto riguarda i
capelli perché vi ma poi con vari colori
tinte e capelli ricci capelli lisci la
cofana c'era sempre
e voi vi chiederete perché soprattutto
magari i ragazzini più giovani che non
hanno vissuto quegli anni in cui c'era
fergie dei black eyed peas che dettava
le regole della moda perché perché lei
aveva questa prima tiratura e la maggior
parte delle ragazze
veniamo a scuola con messi facciamo il
servizio natura molto facile
spoleto infatti un video tutorial
si prendeva di capelli così si o cotona
vano comunque si portavano tutti in
avanti si metteva una bella pinze tira
qui è più alta era più e recapito
come potete notarlo preso alla lettera
perché sembra un gallo un gallo cedrone
benissimo nera abbronzatissima erano
lampade che ai tempi insomma ne abusava
quest'altra foto sempre bionda ecco qui
subentra un'altra colonna portante della
mia vita della vita dei miei capelli
l'extension l'extension che io conservo
tuttora potrei fare un video solo su
quello di tutti i colori di tutti i tipi
di tutte le tipologie di capelli ricci
liscio mosso è striature mass qualsiasi
coniò per ogni persona che avrà anche
poter aprire un negozio
questo in particolare erano bionde come
potete vedere dello stesso colore
c'è quasi del dl dei miei capelli perché
spesso andava in giro anche con colori
diversi per che direte voi perché non
trovavo il colore che voi in testa e
quindi insomma un po cercavo di
abbinarle così a sentimento questa
sempre con le seychelles bionde
lunghissime e cioè mi arrivano
praticamente quasi al sedere
questa sempre biondo ma mi sembra un po
più giallo quindi già qui forse col sole
dell'estate sinistra ingiallire che cosa
è successa cosa è successo quell'estate
no ma a piraino a prendere su questa
foto dove o la cofana la coda finta che
si attaccava qui e le lenti a contatto
grigie ho preso 20 anni in questa foto
sembra una quarantenne qui una co farà
cui ci avevo una ricrescita veramente
pazzesca sempre la cofano di che la
copra di lato con i ricci
così un po concettuale poi questa ecco
questa potevo arrivare a questa foto
quindi qui c'era ciuffo stirato briga di
mezzo ci fu portato di qua cofana
cerchino sottile sottile qui giusto per
far capire la differenza tra ciuffo e
cofano e coda finta mossa qui ero a
gallipoli che cosa è successo a
gallipoli mio tinta i capelli appunto di
biondo già mesi prima insomma
dell'estate con il sole sapete il biondo
bisogna curarlo molto perché già
schiarendo il capello si sfibra quindi
di sottosuolo devi mettere il protettivo
eccetera eccetera io avevo lavorato in
puglia v 12 mesi sotto il sole quindi il
biondo inventato veramente paglia paglia
fieno giallo premendo tornata da
gallipoli non contenta che votre peli in
croce come capelli mi metto le session
cucite quindi proprio quelle che sono
che si fanno le ragazze di colore cucite
qui ha detto con le trecce avevano mi
hanno fatto il senso di un colore più
chiaro nei miei capelli quindi sopra le
stand shame è fatta un'altra tinta
bionda ragazzi
quello è stato il baratro perché io non
avevo più capelli in testa c'è adesso ci
scherza su ma è è stato quasi pari a
quando da piccolo abbiamo fatto i capi
che a spazzola perché non aveva non
sapevo se facevo la coda tanto così di
coda non sapevo vuoi fare disperata e da
quel giorno ha detto basta va assai
station bassa tinte adesso devo curare i
miei capelli
in questa foto potete notare insomma il
cambio radicale cioè i miei capelli
sono tornata insomma il mio colore
naturale iniziato a scurire per tornare
ad essere castana tagliati perché vuole
punte devastate quindi come potete
notare mi arrivavano tipo alla spalla
dalla faccia non ero molto soddisfatta
però dovevo fare qualcosa perché i miei
capelli veramente cadevano a pezzi
quindi inizialmente tirandoli ovviamente
vi arrivavano qui utilizzavano i miei
solite code quindi in questa foto per
esempio potete vedere che oscura qui e
quindi facevo la cofana e poi qua la
codeina micro che avevo la nascondevo
dal codone di extension finto che ho
infatti in questa foto biondo quindi è
un effetto un po shatush kate enti
andava molto di moda
ho iniziato anche ad essere a tenerli
più spesso ricci sempre con l'aiuto
delle station queste erano essentio
reach a clip
lasciamo stare il mood outfit molto
ghetto ma ero in quel mood in quel
periodo
piano piano ovviamente i capelli
crescevano qua avevo sempre le station
però i miei capelli mi ricordo questo
qua che erano già più o meno sotto le
spalle qui ero in sardegna e notare la
bravura o favo fatto le trecce con le
station la clip quindi avevo divise
senso la clip a voi nascosto bene le
clip dietro e mi ero fatta queste tre
c'è proprio io ormai professionista del
capello poi qui apriamo la parentesi
ramato c'è stato un periodo che è durato
poco però in realtà mi piaceva molto
come mi stava questo colore
mi ero fatta un po più ram e quindi con
questi riflessi un po più rossastri qui
sempre riccio capelli già mi erano
cresciuti come potete notare e erano
ritornati le lenti grigie
quindi questo accostamento che devo dire
non mi stava male come colori
qui era una festa di halloween se non
sbaglio o di carnevale non mi ricordo è
sempre con la lente grigia ormai era
fissa
e ritenevo riceverete ricci con un po
diramato a me piaceva abbastanza potrei
ripensarci
qui è ovviamente ritorna la cofana
perché come ho detto prima la cofana
c'era sempre e castana quindi qui avevo
la coda finta castana mi ero jellata
bene lati e la mia comica cofana ed ero
tornata insomma del mio colore
qui era il mio ventesimo compleanno
avevo sempre la coda finta ma qui ecco
questo è uno degli episodi in cui la
coda era più chiara del resto dei
capelli e sip si nota abbastanza
soprattutto col flash magari di sera
speravo che si vedesse poco però col
flash puntato si vedeva rivedibile
insomma ecco diciamo che non erano nè
uno dei migliori chiudiamo la parentesi
del castano perché rullo di tamburi
bionda mi son fatta viola prandelli sono
patara casta nel colore all'appello cosa
manca il nero bravissimi mi sono fatta
nera che si dice mora in realtà io non
mi soffermerei più di tanto sul colore
insomma sul l'oscuro ma sul taglio
perché io mi chiedo che problemi avessi
con i parrucchieri chi mi ha tagliato i
capelli in questo modo cos'è cos'è kick
taglio è o vabbè comunque erano molto
corti quindi secondo me di nuovo le
station mi avevano un po sfigato il
capello è stressato il capello quindi di
nuovo avevo dato un taglio però non
stavo neanche male con questo scuro qui
anche scuri però qua mi sembra avessi le
station
qui invece ero sempre sicura ma col
cappello mosto qui ho già di una milano
ero già all'università se non sbaglio
anche così mi piaceva molto
e qua di nuovo estension quali nuovo
riccia estense questo look proprio super
il puparo
ovviamente è una foto di una serata hip
hop quindi era un motore mood e station
tremende perché sembrano veramente
di plastica non so dove l'ho recuperate
qui il l'oscuro iniziava a scaricarsi un
po quindi stavo tornando piuttosto
castana sempre station ma clip e questa
è una bella foto che vi avevano fatto in
uno shooting questa foto mi fa morire
dalle risate perché allora io la mia
base e scura castana evidentemente mi
ero fatta del dei riflessi sulle punte
po più chiari e sotto le volèe station
tipo biondo scuro quindi senza volerlo
creato tre sfumature sui capelli che
sono quelle che adesso vanno di moda
perché vedo un sacco di gente che c'ha i
tre colori ma ovviamente colori magari
più sgargianti come rosa viola eccetera
eccetera
io ho anticipato da moda perché
rimanendo sul castano altro che shatush
ho fatto lo step successivo cioè castano
castano chiaro e punta bionda qua
veramente top poi anche lì aprire una
parentesi sull'output ma questo potrebbe
essere un altro video gli outfit della
mia vita
fatemi sapere se lo volete che dire
marinese mariners
[Musica]
beh allora conclusione finale
ci sono insomma dei look che non mi
piacciono che non rifarei ci sono dei
look che effettivamente vi stavano
abbastanza bene voi probabilmente da
quando mi conoscete perché da quando
iniziato fuori i video non ho mai
cambiato più di tanto il mio il mio
colore di capelli quindi queste cose di
spiazzeranno perché tanti di voi magari
non avranno la minima idea del fatto che
io per un periodo nome ritengo bionda
gialla direi ovviamente fatemi sapere
cosa ne pensate spero che questo video
insomma fatto divertire e che abbiate ha
scoperto un lato di me e soprattutto
quello del trauma di quand'ero bambina
perché ragazzi veramente mi ha segnato
mi ha segnato in molte qua dal
parrucchiere a spuntare più di tutte le
altre donne c'è l'ansia perché sono
rimasta traumatizzata e detto questo se
avete quasi tipo di domanda consiglio
eccetera eccetera
scrivetelo qui sotto io vi mando un
bacione ci vediamo al prossimo v
ciao ciao adoro
[Musica]